- [Zac] What lies beneath
the dark subconscious
of a faceless silent killer?
What is present behind the black eyes
of what was just a six-year-old child
on Halloween night in 1963?
One psychiatric doctor by
the name of Samuel Loomis
was prepared to find out
what goes bump in the night
within the mind of Haddonfield,
Illinois's boogeyman,
Michael Myers.
To learn the fate of Dr. Loomis's fiance
and how it might've changed
his entire life going forward,
stick around to the end of this video.
(metal intro music)
Welcome to "Horror History."
In today's lesson, I am analyzing the man
who tried to understand
an incomprehensible evil.
There are many versions of this character
because there are many alternate timelines
in the "Halloween" story.
I like to think of the
timeline like a train map,
the "Halloween Express."
Today, I'll just be analyzing
the original timeline where Dr. Loomis
is portrayed by actor Donald Pleasence.
There may be other videos where we ride
the Halloween Express
down alternate routes.
If you want to make
things more complicated,
there is a theory that
the character Sam Loomis
in "Psycho" is the very same Sam Loomis
as the one in the "Halloween" series.
Sam Loomis in "Psycho"
follows a private investigator
to find his missing
girlfriend, Marion Crane.
But before Sam can find her,
she's already dead alongside
the private investigator.
This theory says that Sam
was driven to the obsession
of learning how the criminal mind works,
which leads him to take the
job at Smith's Grove Sanitarium
where he meets Michael.
As much fun as that idea is,
personally, I think "Halloween" Sam Loomis
was just named after "Psycho" Sam Loomis
because director John
Carpenter was paying homage
to a great movie that
inspired the slasher genre.
In order for me to turn
Dr. Loomis's psychoanalysis
back at him, I'm going to take it back
to his first appearance in the franchise.
(ominous music)
Dr. Samuel Loomis began
his psychological studies
of the feared Michael Myers
on November 5th, 1963,
when Michael was admitted
to Smith's Grove Sanitarium.
Michael was silent and
unmoving after the murder
of his sister, Judith Myers.
Dr. Loomis seemed to think
that he was experiencing
severe trauma and damage
to a psychological health.
He opted for specialized
treatment to try to penetrate
through Michael's unwavering
lack of emotional response.
The early months of
Loomis's care for Michael
are mostly a mystery
because this time period
is never covered in the Halloween canon.
However, if we look at the
non-canon Chaos Comics material,
we can get a little bit more backstory.
This is one of those cases where the comic
doesn't contradict anything in the movies,
and it can potentially
help us understand Loomis
a little bit better, so I'm kind of okay
with talking about it,
as long as we remember that
this technically doesn't count.
Loomis requested his
supervisor, Dr. Carpenter,
to move Michael into a
private room safely away
from the other juveniles of the building.
But Dr. Carpenter declined
to Loomis's request
and kept Michael where he
was with the other juveniles.
There was one other
doctor at the Sanitarium
that saw Michael the
same way that Loomis did,
a woman by the name of Jennifer Hill.
He asked her to speak with Dr. Carpenter
with him in order to convince him
that Michael needed to be moved.
Dr. Hill did agree to do this
under the condition that
Loomis take her out to dinner.
And although their attempt
to get Michael moved
to solitary was not successful,
Dr. Hill's attempt at romance was,
and the two started dating, bonding
over their shared beliefs
about psychotherapy.
Over the next few months,
a few incidents took place
with the other juveniles at the facility,
like Michael shoving a crayon
deep into the fellow patient
Tony O'Malley's left eye.
This was before security
cameras were common
so Loomis and the Smith's Grove staff
could not find any evidence
that Michael was responsible
and ended up blaming another child.
In November, a child by
the name of Adrian Wade
ate an entire birthday cake
that was supposed to be given to Michael.
Shortly after, Adrian was
found in the shower room
with second degree
burns all over his body.
He later died in the
hospital of heart failure.
After months of further study of Michael
and his psychological health,
Dr. Loomis started to believe
that the young Meyers boy
did not suffer from trauma
that occurred on Halloween 1963,
but found that behind his
eyes leaked only darkness.
He had no conscience, no remorse,
no response to the perception
of life, death, consequence,
or right and wrong.
Only a psyche of pure evil.
(eerie reel clicking)
- I spent eight years trying to reach him
and then another seven
trying to keep him locked up
because I realized that what was living
behind that boy's eyes was
purely and simply evil.
- On May 1st, 1964, only
months after Michael
was admitted to Smith's Grove Sanitarium,
Loomis met with two of the
lead doctors of the facility
to try to move Michael to
a maximum security ward
in Litchfield, Illinois.
The two doctors refused
Loomis's suggestion
stating that Michael was
in a state of comatose
and did not react to
anything in his surroundings,
but Loomis did not agree.
Loomis believed that Michael
was using the state of mind
to cover up his true dark behaviors
and insisted he'd be moved somewhere else
where it would be impossible
for him to escape.
The doctors then gave Loomis a choice;
either Loomis would continue
working with Michael
at Smith's Grove or someone else
would be assigned to the patient.
Loomis reluctantly agreed
to the doctors' terms
because he felt that no
one else could be trusted
to work with him.
It makes me wonder if things
could have gone differently
if another doctor had
worked closely with Michael.
It seems like one of the main issues
was that most of the other
doctors didn't believe
that such a young boy
could be so full of evil.
So it might've benefited
Loomis to have someone else
see the patient from his perspective.
The only one who really kind
of understood the danger that
Michael posed was his
girlfriend, Dr. Hill.
As the two continue to get closer,
they were eventually engaged
with a wedding planned for December 1971.
However, disaster would strike
before the big day would come.
In October 1971, Dr. Carpenter
threw a Halloween party
at the Sanitarium, which Loomis
was heavily in opposition of.
That night the electricity went out
and a girl by the name
of Nancy was found dead,
drowned during a game
of Bobbing for Apples.
The same night, Dr. Hill was found dead
outside of the Sanitarium.
Her death was ruled a suicide
because it seemed that she either fell out
or jumped off the roof of the building.
But Loomis knew better.
He knew in his gut that
Jennifer would not kill herself.
And he couldn't see a scenario
that didn't involve Michael
getting his hands dirty.
I think this was really
the last straw for him.
Jennifer was the one person
that Loomis could connect to,
not only in terms of his
personal life, but also at work.
She was the only other person
who could see Michael's true nature.
I think this must be when he snapped
and made it his life's
goal to suppress the evil
lurking inside of the Sanitarium.
For the next seven years, he did his best
to keep Michael locked away from society.
And this strategy worked
until the night of
October 30th, 1978, where
Michael escaped from captivity
to bring evil upon Haddonfield once again.
(ominous music)
(soft ominous music)
Loomis and his assistant,
Nurse Marion Chambers,
were given the assignment
of transporting Michael
from Smith's Grove Sanitarium
to his home county of
Livingston for trial.
The week prior, Michael had
turned 21 and was due in court
to see if he was fit to be released.
On the drive up to Smith's Grove,
Loomis continually refers
to Michael as "it,"
which Marion catches onto.
- [Marion] Don't you think we
can refer to "it" as "him."
- If you say so.
- Here, Loomis shows that
he no longer sees Michael
as a human, but as an
embodiment of pure evil.
He suggests that Marion
should give Michael
a dose of Thorazine,
which is a strong drug
used to control psychotic disorders,
causing her to realize that
Loomis doesn't want Michael
to have any chance of winning his trial.
As they get closer to the facility,
they noticed several of the
patients wandering the grounds
which strikes dread into him
because he fears that
Michael may have escaped.
He runs up to the gates
to use the telephone,
trying to warn the staff,
when Michael jumps on the roof of the car
and grabs Marion through the window.
Loomis is unable to stop Michael,
as he chases and out of
the car, gets inside,
and frantically drives away.
Strangely, Loomis
doesn't seem that shocked
at Michael's ability to operate a car.
Even though he'd been
locked up since age six
and probably had never even been in a car
over the last 15 years.
His response all ties back
to the idea that Michael
is no man, but rather just an
incarnation of evil itself.
We're just seeing how
desensitized he has become to it.
In fact, he already knows
Michael is on his way back
to Haddonfield for Halloween
and drives in that direction.
On his way, he discovers
Michael's medical gown
and the matchbook that Marion
had used the night before,
so he knows he's on the right track.
He decides to investigate the
grave site of Judith Myers
only to find her headstone
has been removed,
confirming his suspicion
that Michael has come home.
After enlisting the help
of the local sheriff,
Leigh Brackett, the two checkout
Michael's old residence at 45 Lampkin Lane
which has been broken into.
The two discover Michael's
first confirmed victim
of the evening, a dog
they found in the house.
See, I can kind of disagree
but sympathize with Michael
wanting to take out humans, but a dog?
That's just messed up man.
Loomis convinces Sheriff Brackett
that Michael was probably
nearby and needs to be captured.
It's here that we see
that despite his bravery
to try to spot Michael,
Loomis is terrified
of Haddonfield's so-called boogeyman
and the capabilities that he possesses.
Loomis eventually discovers
the stolen sanitarium vehicle
from the night before across the street.
He walks the streets of Haddonfield
until later that evening,
he sees two young kids running
out of a house screaming.
Loomis is able to recognize their screams
as true terror, as opposed to
an innocent Halloween prank.
(man yells)
(group laughs)
And he runs into the
house to find 17-year old
Laurie Strode being strangled by Michael.
Laurie manages to pull
Michael's mask off for a moment,
giving Loomis time to shoot him.
How many times Dr. Loomis?
- [Sam] I shot him six times!
- [Zac] Which sends Michael
over the balcony railing
onto the lawn.
By the time Loomis tends to Laurie
and looks over the balcony,
his former patient is no longer there.
Michael had vanished and we
can visibly see how shaken up
Dr. Loomis is by the
realization that his nemesis
isn't just evil, inhuman, and
possibly the devil incarnate,
but also invincible.
Loomis looks out into the world
wondering where Michael has gone next.
The next door neighbor comes out
and helps Loomis get ahold of the police.
So the search continues
leading to this incident.
(eerie reel clicking)
(suspenseful music and
car tires screeching)
(car explodes)
Sheriff Brackett asks if
this victim is Michael,
but before they find
out, Brackett is informed
that his teenage daughter,
Annie, was found dead.
Sheriff Brackett identified the body
and set off to tell his
wife of the circumstances,
which he blames on Loomis.
That's gotta be crushing for Dr. Loomis.
He tried to warn the psychiatric hospital
how dangerous Michael was for 15 years,
then he got away, Dr. Loomis's
worst nightmares came true
despite his best efforts,
and after all of that he still shoulders
the brunt of the blame.
That kind of treatment
just makes a guy go.
(Loomis yells)
Deputy Hunt would fill in for Brackett
from that point forward.
Hunt believes that the
crash victim is Michael,
which may have just been wishful thinking
because Loomis is not convinced.
The dentist at the coroner's office
estimated the burned body from his teeth
to be about 17 years old,
although a full check of dental records
would take hours to complete.
I think some part of
Loomis knows that Michael
is still on the loose,
so he convinced Deputy Hunt to
a further patrol of the town.
Loomis directs him back
to the Myers house,
thinking that maybe if
Michael was injured,
the familiarity of his old home
could have give him security
in his vulnerable state.
The house is already being swept by police
while local townsfolk mob
outside and vandalize the place
as some kind of weird post
tragedy form of protest.
It's there that a pair of high
school boys express concern
to Deputy Hunt because
their friend Bennett Tramer
didn't get home after
leaving a costume party.
Hunt and Loomis both suspect the worst
that the burned body belonged to Tramer,
meaning that Myers must
still be out there.
Before being able to
really put together a plan,
they're called to
Haddonfield Elementary school
where another break-in has taken place,
possibly their chance to catch Michael.
They discover a child's
picture of a family
decorated with a knife that
Michael has left piercing
the daughter's heart.
On the chalkboard,
the word "Samhain" is written in red
and Loomis is the only one
that knows its Celtic origin.
It's essentially an ancient
Gaelic festival of the dead
celebrating the end of summer
and the beginning of winter,
which began on what we now
know is Halloween night.
They're interrupted by Nurse Chambers
who informs Dr. Loomis that the Governor
has ordered him to leave Haddonfield
under the belief that he's
contributing to the hysteria.
Loomis at first refuses,
he desperately wants
to find and stop Michael.
This is where we really see his behavior
cross over from a
concerned into obsessive.
Michael Myers said essentially
become his life's work
and he didn't have anything
or anyone else to go back to.
He was ready to try to stop
Michael, no matter the cost.
However, there was already a
state marshal waiting outside.
So Loomis had no choice but to be escorted
by him and Marion.
I mean, I never understood
why he doesn't just try
to sneak out the back.
I guess he just knows
that medicine is his thing
and stealth is not.
However, once in the police car,
he learns of a secret
government sealed document,
which would change
everything he thought he knew
about Michael's rampage.
(ominous music)
(fast eerie music)
On the car ride back into Smith's Grove,
Marion drops this bomb on Dr. Loomis.
(eerie reel clicking)
- There's a file on Michael
Myers that nobody knew about.
- I've seen everything.
- No, no.
It was hidden, sealed by the court
after his parents were killed.
Now after the Governor
heard what happened tonight,
he authorized Dr. Rogers to open it.
That girl, that Strode girl,
that's Michael Myers's sister.
- Loomis has the revelation that Michael
is in Haddonfield to finish
what he started 15 years ago
by taking out the other sister.
So he pleads with the marshal
to take him to the hospital
where Laurie is being
kept, but to no avail.
So in a fit of desperation,
he grabs his revolver
and to show he's serious,
fires a shot through the passenger window
and demands to be taken to the hospital.
You can't just do that.
I mean, where does he
think he is, LA county?
Loomis's desperation is starting
to get the better of him.
By threatening an officer
of the law at gunpoint,
he's basically declaring
that he'll try to stop the
bogeyman of Haddonfield,
even if it means destroying himself.
Dr. Samuel Loomis turned
from a by-the-book,
concerned psychiatrist to a
man overcome with obsession.
I might normally compare his behavior
against a medically recognized disorder
as I have for some other
characters that I've analyzed,
but as far as I can tell, he
doesn't really have a disorder.
He's just obsessed with stopping Michael,
and given what he's been through,
it's not impossible to blame him.
I think about every group project ever.
Loomis has tried to convince
others and work with others
to prevent a disaster,
but eventually they all let him down
and he's going to do it himself,
even if this leads him down a dark road
of aggression and even committing crimes.
It's probably a good thing too,
because he arrives at Haddonfield Hospital
just in time to save Laurie
from Michael's wrath.
The state marshal is not so lucky.
- [Sam] No!
(eerie music)
- I guess Loomis is off the hook?
But also no, because he's once again
face-to-face with Michael,
and Michael is invincible.
He and Laurie run to try to
take cover in an operating room,
but Michael easily tears through the door
and stabs his doctor in the
stomach before turning his rage
against Laurie who managed to
get ahold of Loomis's revolver
and shoot Michael in the eyes
to temporarily blind him.
Meanwhile, Loomis realizes it's
going to take something more
than bullets or like a
cleverly placed trail
of Reece's Pieces to stop
Michael and devises a plan
to trap him by opening the
compressed gas canisters
in the room before saying this.
- It's time Micheal.
- [Zac] And after giving
Laurie a moment to run for it,
he lights the place up,
potentially sacrificing himself
to put a stop to the evil
that inhabits the mind of his patient.
On the morning of November
1st, the ambos role.
That means ambulances came.
My mom heard it on a medical show once
and thought it was hilarious
so I'm just going to go with it.
Somehow, by some miracle, Dr. Sam Loomis
survived the massive explosion
at Haddonfield Hospital
and the seemingly fatal
stab to his abdomen.
He would live on with major
burns scars on his face
and walk with a limp needing to use a cane
for the rest of his life.
Not too bad for being blown up
as a 60 year old man, right?
Those must've been some real fast ambos.
However, as expected,
Michael isn't entirely
out of the picture yet either,
but he does go into a coma,
allowing him to be
captured and placed back
into a psychiatric facility.
Despite Michael spending
the next 10 years in a coma,
Loomis is still obsessed
and still fears the evil
that lurks within him.
His new life's work is to prevent anyone
from living through the Halloween night
that he and Laurie escaped.
As more time passes, Michael
is seen as less and less
of a threat by his peers.
Only he and Laurie know that one day,
Michael will rise again.
And then it's just him because
Laurie passes away in 1987,
leaving behind a daughter named Jamie.
A year after her death,
Loomis is still fighting
just as hard to keep Michael locked up.
The staff actually go behind
his back to transfer Michael
from the high security facility he's at,
Ridgemont Federal Sanitarium,
back to Smith's Grove
on October 30th, 1988.
Loomis immediately goes in to object
when he finds out, and to his horror,
learns of an accident that occurred
during the patient transport.
Without another word, he
storms out of the room
to find his patient once
again and prevent a repeat
of what happened 10 years
earlier to this day.
This time he suspects Michael
will be coming after
Laurie Strode's daughter,
Jamie Lloyd, the closest living relative.
When Loomis sees the accident site,
he's not too convinced
that it was an accident
and heads back to
Haddonfield for another round
of serial killer hide-and-seek.
- [Grace] Hide-and-Seek?
Are we really going to play that?
- [Zac] No, not you.
Go away.
Loomis stops at a gas station,
but upon further investigation,
he finds more than he was expecting.
For one, if you thought Loomis
was obsessed with Michael
get a load of this gas
station diner owner.
I think he's even more obsessed
with Regular Abraham Lincoln.
Loomis finds the owner
tied up in metal chains
and some woman on the floor
who also bit the dust.
He tries to dial out for
help, but to his surprise,
all of the phones had been broken.
To be fair, Michael's
not going to use them,
he doesn't talk.
But the biggest surprise
for Loomis is behind him.
No, I mean the other direction.
He turns and finds Michael
standing in the kitchen,
just staring at him.
Loomis pleads with him not
to return to Haddonfield.
- If you want another victim, take me.
But leave those people in peace.
- With no response, Loomis
shoots off four rounds
from his gun but it's no
good, Michael vanishes.
Loomis runs outside to find him
when a truck smashes
through the garage doors.
Loomis shoots are four
more rounds to no avail.
Michael intentionally
sideswipes the gas pump
and the explosion and blows up
Loomis's car in the process.
I always love how if you
look closely at the car,
it just jumps off the ground.
(eerie music and car explodes)
Dr. Sam probably didn't
find it so funny though.
He's now stranded without a
way of catching up to Michael
and the hell that he's about
to unleash on Haddonfield.
Loomis walks down the lonely
road and after being punked
by some kids, is picked up
by Reverend Jackson Sayer,
who tells him that you can't kill evil.
- [Sayer] It don't die like a man dies.
- Loomis understands this all too well.
He's been living with the
consequences of that since 1978.
Sayer drops him at the
Haddonfield Police Station
and he warns the new sheriff, Ben Meeker.
Just like practically everyone,
Meeker doesn't believe him at first.
Imagine if people just listened to doctors
when they warn about dangerous things.
After some debate, the
sheriff reluctantly declares
a state of emergency and all
of Haddonfield's citizens
are told to lock down
inside of their homes.
Imagine if they actually listened.
Dr. Loomis probably thinks
about Michael's attack pattern
10 years ago to make his next move.
In '78, Michael went to his childhood home
to try to find his sister Laurie,
so this time Loomis suspects that he'll go
to the adoptive home of his niece, Jamie.
There, he finds pictures of
Laurie scattered on the floor
and the family dog.
Loomis is too late, but
he does learn that Michael
is indeed repeating his 1978 rampage.
Loomis and Meeker search the town
and find Jamie trick or treating
with her adoptive sister Rachel.
They're picked up and
put in the squad car,
but find themselves immediately surrounded
by the very thing they were
supposed to be protected from.
(eerie music)
- Dear God.
(suspenseful music)
(fast beat eerie music)
- [Zac] After discovering
that some pranksters in town
were doing a little Michael Myers cosplay,
and nearly shooting them,
Loomis and Sheriff Meeker
returned to the police station
to find it completely destroyed,
with Michael also having
demoted one of the deputies
to "Halloween decoration",
if you know what I mean.
A good old group of Illinois boys show up
at the police station, demanding to know
what was going on in Haddonfield.
Loomis tells them that
Michael has returned,
which Meeker isn't happy with,
claiming that he just created a lynch mob.
However, Loomis seems
undisturbed by this accusation.
- You haven't got a police force.
These men may be the only defense you got.
- [Zac] Being the only adult alive
that has witnessed the sheer
horror that is Michael,
it seems that he's willing
to just take whatever help
he can get.
He obviously did not realize
that cops do it by the book.
I have no idea what that means still.
They bring Jamie and Rachel
to the only safe place
they have left, Sheriff Meeker's home,
where with the help of Deputy Logan,
they arm themselves
and board the place up.
Satisfied with Jamie's safety,
Loomis goes back on the offensive
and tries to return to
Jamie's house to find Michael.
He doesn't find him, but
he does later that night,
run back into Jamie as
she is running from him
and decides to take her to
the schoolhouse for safety.
A school may have actually
been considered safe back then,
I don't know, but I guess this
school would be considered
an exception because Michael
is already there waiting
for them and throws Loomis
through a glass door.
(glass shattering)
Loomis is pretty metal.
I mean, he's been stabbed, blown up,
and now thrown through a door.
Seems like he's just as
hard to kill as Michael is.
Loomis is present later on when the police
and the Illinois boys all
shoot Michael down at once,
sending him into a
well, and interestingly,
he seems to believe that Michael
is actually dead this time,
despite years of evidence
that Michael's death
is simply not a possibility.
- Micheal Meyers is in Hell.
Buried where he belongs.
- It seems out of character
for Loomis to be that naive.
Doesn't it?
My take is that he was
about 70 at this point
and he probably didn't think
you'd be around if Michael
came back after another 10 years or so.
Almost like he needed to
believe that Michael was dead
so he could die in peace.
Obviously, the real reason is
that director Dwight Little,
didn't really want to make
another "Halloween" movie,
but this is a video about
Loomis, not Dwight Little.
(sad music, distorted)
Dr. Loomis returns home
with Jamie and her family
to help them settle back in,
but after hearing a chilling scream,
Loomis rushes to the
stairway to find Jamie
holding a pair of scissors.
Loomis cannot believe what he sees.
The evil he's spent the last
25 years trying to vanquish
is now logged into the
body of the one girl
that he was able to save.
To put this into perspective,
this is like playing a whole game,
but then your file gets deleted at 99%.
Loomis's psyche begins to break.
The terror of the idea that
the evil had just latched
onto another soul is too
much for him to bear.
And he raises his gun to shoot,
but not before being
stopped by Sheriff Meeker.
However, the circumstances
are not quite as bad
as they first seemed.
Over the next year, Jamie
seems to get control
of the evil connection she now has.
She is now the newest
patient of Dr. Loomis,
but she doesn't become
an empty soulless shape
like Michael had.
She does, however, go
mute due to the trauma
of the year before and
suffers from what seem to be
terrors and seizures in the nights,
but Loomis seems to know that
there's more to it than that.
For his own sake,
it's probably a good thing
that he's able to work
with Jamie, because he now has
something to live for again.
But because he's so jaded now,
it often comes off as
kind of scary for her.
Loomis comes and checks on Jamie one day
during her stay at the facility
while Rachel and her
friend Tina are visiting.
A brick smashes through
the window with a note
attached reading, "The
evil child must die!"
Loomis believes that people of Haddonfield
are afraid of Jamie because they think
that she's following
in Michael's footsteps.
On October 31st, 1989, one a
year into his care for her,
Jamie drew something that
caught Loomis's attention,
a horrific drawing of the family dog Max.
I would not want to be a dog
in Haddonfield in late October.
Loomis called the family's
home to check on Max,
because he had discovered
that Jamie could sense things.
He aggressively demanded
that she write down
whatever she knew.
- Write, write, write!
For me, this is the point
of no return for Loomis.
He has good intentions,
but he doesn't treat Jamie
with the same patience
that he gave Michael early on.
Jamie soon suffers another
seizure, which convinces Loomis
that she's mentally linked to Michael.
He tells Sheriff Meeker
about how he believes
that Michael is still alive.
- Hell would not have him.
- [Zac] But the sheriff is
called away to the cemetery
and so Loomis returns to
try to get more answers
out of Jamie.
(equipment clatters)
- What about your stepmother, Jamie?
- Harry!
Harry, did you put your
name in the Goblet of Fire!
He then tells Jamie of
his trip to the cemetery
where supposedly someone
had dug up the coffin
of a nine year old girl.
- What do you think he's
going to do with that?
- Whoa, man.
He also tries searching
the Meyers house again,
but honestly, what is he going
to do to him at this point?
He shot him several times, blew him up,
loaded him with bullets again,
and yet Michael still lives on.
For these reasons,
I don't think he was
there to find Michael.
I think he was there to set a trap,
which would come into play
later that Halloween night.
(ominous music)
(eerie music)
Dr. Loomis decides to stay
by Jamie's side that evening
as she attends her school's costume party.
It's here that she has another vision.
Thanks to her connection with her uncle,
which helps them figure
out that Tina Williams
was in danger near Dale's
gas station across town.
And Loomis gets Sheriff
Meeker on the phone
to help save her.
Tina returns to the
clinic to comfort Jamie
for a short period of time but decides
to attend a Halloween
party later that evening.
Loomis begs her to stay,
thinking that she's still
going to be in danger,
but Tina doesn't believe
him and blames him
for filling Jamie's head
with all of these boogeyman stories.
The interaction shows
that he's become seen
by the younger people in town
as more of a crazy old man
than an experienced Michael
Myers veteran and survivor.
Loomis instructs the local
police to follow her.
However, Jamie sees that Tina
is going to be in danger again
and sneaks out to try to warn her herself.
- Jamie's not in her room.
She's nowhere in sight.
(child laughs)
- [Girl] Hey!
(child screams)
- [Meeker] Loomis!
What the hell are you doing?
- [Male Speaker] Take it easy.
- My thoughts, exactly.
The guy is just out of control.
However, he still keeps
finding ways to be helpful
as he helps the police find Jamie
who had escaped with their
classmate, Billy Hill,
near an old barn.
They were not in time to save Tina,
but Jamie and Billy
are escorted to safety.
Jamie is gaining some of her voice back
and she asks if Loomis will
be able to kill Michael
to which he replies.
- I think so.
- For some reason,
even though nothing in this
26 year span should lead him
to believe that Michael is mortal.
On the bright side for them,
this causes Jamie to agree
to help Loomis and the
police by using her visions
to help locate and catch Michael.
As the ambos and police
officers leave the scene,
Loomis approaches the edge of the forest
and yells into the trees at Michael,
claiming that his rage
will destroy him someday,
that killing everyone
will not make it go away.
He instructs Michael to go home
where Loomis and Jamie
will be waiting for him.
Sure enough, they set up
Jamie in Judith's old room
as the police surround the house
and wait for Haddonfield's
silent killer to approach.
Loomis is waiting in the hall
when he's called into the room
because Jamie's having another one
of her psychic connection episodes.
This time, it appears that
Billy is the one in danger,
though I guess you could argue
that this was all a diversion
based on what happens in that next.
Loomis radios the sheriff
and tells him that Michael
is at the Children's Clinic.
So Meeker sends all of his officers there,
leaving the outside of
the house unguarded.
It seems like this was
Loomis his plan all along.
It could be that he figures
Michael will not show up
if the police are all
around or maybe he thought
that with fewer people,
there'll be fewer casualties.
Plus, this kind of allows
him to operate the way
that he wants to, which
as we'll see shortly,
is probably not something that
anyone on the police force
would have approved of.
He tells the one remaining
officer to stay with Jamie
as he descends towards the
main level of the house
where Michael is coming in
and they meet face-to-face once again.
Knowing he's here for
Jamie, Loomis informs him
that he believes Jamie can
stop the rage inside of him.
He reminds him of how he used to be
before the rage engulfed him.
He's trying to break through to Michael
on a more human level,
a side of him that the doctor
had long thought to be dead.
Why does he suddenly think
he can reach some semblance
of humanity buried inside
of his former patient?
It's because of Jamie.
Jamie was supposedly overcome
by the same evil that affected
that affected Michael,
but she was able to overcome it
and go back to being a good person.
He tries to take Michael's
knife away from him gently
until Michael cuts him across the stomach
and throws him through a railing.
(Loomis gasps and screams)
(glass shatters)
(Loomis yells)
Michael follows the sound of Jamie
and the officer upstairs trying to escape.
And after Jamie is
almost killed by Michael,
about a hundred times,
she runs back downstairs
and finds Loomis there to comfort her,
but things take a turn for the worse.
Instead of running away
like normal people,
Loomis decides to lure and
taunt Michael with Jamie,
using her as bait at
the end of the stairs.
- [Loomis] You want her!
- [Jamie] No!
- Here she is!
- This is almost
definitely the worst thing
that he's ever done because
judging by her reaction,
Jamie had no idea that she
was going to be used as bait
like this in such a close
encounter with her masked stalker.
- [ColossalIsCrazy] This is the
face of the clinically insane.
If you see this man do not engage him.
- [Sam] Micheal, let's play a game.
- Yep, he is officially crossed
into Jigsaw territory now.
- Catch the little girl.
- Okay, so he's not actually
giving her up to him at least,
I guess that's slightly redeeming.
When Michael reaches
the middle of the room,
Loomis pulls a rope, releasing
a net made with heavy chains.
He also loads him up with
darts from a tranquilizer gun,
and in a moment of madness,
just savagely beats him
with this wooden board.
- [Sam] Die!
Die!
Die, Michael!
- Not sure that's going to do a lot,
but it probably felt good.
- [Chris] I didn't know where I
was for a minute, felt good though.
- The police show up and
place Michael in holding,
which is glossed over, but it's
a huge milestone for Loomis.
People are finally seeing
Michael the way that he sees him
and they're willing to
put him in an actual jail
rather than dumping him in
another psychiatric facility.
The plan is to transfer him
to a maximum security facility
where he would stay until death
or in his case just forever.
Unfortunately for Haddonfield
and its police force,
forever ends up not even
being more than a night
because a mysterious character
in a black trench coat
shows up, takes out the
entire police station
and frees Michael Myers.
I compared Dr. Loomis to Jigsaw earlier,
so I guess this guy is Hoffman.
- Game over.
- Michael was free to
exercise his immortality
against the people of
Haddonfield once more.
But Dr. Loomis's health
would finally get the better
of him as he suffered a
stroke not long after.
(eerie music)
(suspenseful piano music)
I imagine that Halloween in 1989
was the biggest rollercoaster
that Samuel Loomis
ever went through.
He had finally found
Michael, captured him,
only for him to be released
by another powerful evildoer.
Based on the information we have,
Loomis suffered a stroke
sometime after this.
But I like to imagine that
it was the same night.
Right when he found out
that Michael had escaped,
his brain basically freaked
out and he ends up realizing
that he can't go on like this anymore.
For the better of his health,
he retired from his position
at Smith's Grove Sanitarium
and moved to a secluded lifestyle
in a cabin in rural Illinois.
He also got surgery to remove
the burn scars from his face.
Everything was peaceful
for the next six years
until he got a visit from an old friend
on October 30th, 1995, his
old boss, Dr. Terrance Wynn,
comes in to see him
on that dark rainy night,
Wynn had come to celebrate
his own retirement
and wants to convince Loomis
to go back as chief
administrator of Smith's Grove.
It's during this discussion
that Loomis recognizes a
familiar voice on the radio
calling for help.
That voice belongs to
Jamie, now 15 years old,
and her body is discovered
mutilated the next morning,
Halloween 1995.
Loomis knows that the
nightmare has returned.
And Michael Myers was back for round six.
Despite the fact that he's
already on borrowed time
and being in his mid seventies
and having endured a handful
of life-threatening scenarios,
he just can't turn a cold shoulder
to the city of Haddonfield.
Even now, they still don't seem
to have any respect for him,
despite all he's been through for them.
- It's been quiet here for six years
and that's the way it's going to stay.
The last thing I need
now is you going around
spouting off ghost stories.
- Loomis quickly retorts that
Michael Myers is his business.
He's now a part of the
legend of Michael Myers.
The townspeople almost see him
as synonymous with Michael,
as if he's some kind of warning sign
that the boogeyman is back.
Loomis and Wynn go to the
hospital to visit Jamie,
when he's approached by an
even older familiar face.
This is Tommy Doyle, the little boy
that Laurie Strode was babysitting
on that fateful Halloween night in 1978.
Tommy starts to tell him
about other relatives
in the Strode family that are now living
in Michael's old house,
but he's rushed out of
the hospital by security
before he can tell the whole story.
Tommy tells him to meet
him at the campus rally
at nine that night and Loomis knows
that he'll have to prepare himself
to face his old patient one last time.
As per tradition, he pays a
visit to Michael's old house,
but it's new residents
aren't home when he arrived.
So he just makes like
a video game character
and lets himself inside.
Eventually he meets
these Strode matriarch,
Debra Strode, and warns
her of his suspicion
of Michael's immediate return.
He urges her and her family
to immediately leave town.
When he gets back to the hospital,
he learns that Jamie was
offed the previous night.
He confronts Jamie's doctor,
outraged, and in a great amount of pain
because of Jamie's passing.
Remember, Jamie was essentially
Dr. Loomis's greatest work.
He was able to save her
from becoming the next Michael Meyers.
The conversation does yield
an interesting piece
of information though.
If there's some kind of a law
about sharing a patient's
medical information,
the doctor ignores it and reveals
that he found placental
fluids in Jamie's body,
meaning she had given birth
about 24 hours before.
Only they did not know where the baby was.
Loomis, on the other hand, thinks he does.
He meets Tommy at the campus
rally looking to talk further,
but first they discover
another Meyers casualty.
This time, the body of radio
personality, Barry Simms.
Loomis and Tommy returned
to the boarding house
that Tommy is staying at across the street
from the old Meyers house but
they discover that the baby,
which Tommy is named
Steven, is now missing.
There were also two other
Strodes taking cover
in Tommy's room, Kara
Strode and her son, Danny.
These are the adoptive
cousins of Laurie Strode,
and they're also now missing,
but they're soon discovered
when Michael chases them to the front door
and Tommy lets them in.
Tommy asks Loomis 'who else
knew about the baby Steven?'
Which leads him to
having a big realization.
(eerie reel clicking)
- Who else knew I had the baby?
- No one.
- [Tommy] No.
There had to be someone else.
Who knew?
- Nobody knew expect me and...
- They turned to the
living room and see Danny,
sitting on the lap of the
mysterious black trench coat man
who helped free Michael in 1989,
who turns out to be none other
than the retiring Smith's
Grove administrator,
Dr. Terrance Wynn.
Loomis discovers that Wynn
is part of an organization
called the "Cult of Thorn"
who worships the demon Thorn,
the same evil that possessed
Michael Myers since 1963,
and can not leave his body until he kills
the last remaining member
of Michael's family.
This explains Michael's entire life.
Since that first dreaded Halloween,
which was now 32 years ago.
Dr. Loomis takes Tommy
Doyle back to Smith's Grove
one last time and asked
Tommy to wait in the hall
as he confronts Wynn, who invites him
to join the Cult of Thorn.
Loomis isn't having any of that though,
and is prepared to shoot Dr. Wynn,
but one of the cult
members sneaks up on him
and knocks him out.
(Loomis groans in pain)
He wakes up around the time that Tommy
has rescued Kara,
Steven, and Danny Strode,
and helps them get away from Michael
by shooting the controls for the door
and hailing an elevator
for Kara and the kids.
Tommy catches up with
them and invites Loomis
to flee the hospital with them.
But Loomis's decision goes
back to the decision he made
when all of this Cult
of Thorn business began.
He was happily retired
when he discovered
Michael's return in 1995
And he made the decision
to come back to Haddonfield
to try to stop Michael one last time.
He knew he didn't have
much gas left in the tank
and he was never planning on
walking away with his own life.
We never see exactly what his fate is,
but his story ends on this shot
where Michael has shed
his mask on the floor
next to a syringe
and we hear Loomis cry out one final time
before his story ends.
(Loomis screams)
I've always interpreted
this ending to mean
that Loomis eventually lost his life
doing what he dedicated it to,
trying to hunt down his most
infamous psychiatric patient.
Technically speaking, it's
a very ambiguous ending.
You could say that both of their fates
at the end of this timeline
will always be unknown.
The reason for my interpretation
has more to do with the context behind it.
The original ending known,
as the "Producer's Cut,"
shows Loomis going back to Smith's Grove
and discovering what he thinks is Michael,
but turns out to be Dr. Wynn
with the iconic Michael Myers
mask placed over his face,
leaving the story open
for another chapter.
But sadly, the actor Donald Pleasance
passed away shortly after filming.
So the ending was reworked
for the theatrical cut,
which is technically canon,
and gives us a more of a proper conclusion
to Loomis's story.
We see Dr. Samuel Loomis turned
from a clinical psychologist,
treating mentally distressed children,
to a man obsessed with the destruction
of one of his patients.
While that doesn't sound like
the most noble of characters
on the surface, when you break him down,
you discover that he
puts the care of others
first in his heart,
and even before himself,
he's a selfless man giving
his time and his energy
to protect the town of Haddonfield
and the Strode family line.
And he continues to do so,
even though none of the people
he saves end up respecting him.
His later years were corrupted
by his growing obsession
with stopping his adversary,
which only worsened his reputation
but he kept on fighting
right down to the very end.
Let me know in the comments
what Halloween character
you'd like to see me cover
next on "Horror History."
There are a ton of options.
For example, the Rob
Zombie timeline version
of Dr. Loomis is a different
character that I could analyze.
That leaves us with like four Laurie's,
four Michael's, and probably
two or three Tommy's.
We could be at this for a while.
So let me know who you really want to see.
You'll find all of those videos
in the playlist on the left.
Remember to subscribe to CZSWorld
for new horrors every week,
ring the death bell for all notifications.
And I'll see you in the next
one, assuming we both survive.
(upbeat techno music)